strict process the fda has reaffirmed
its findings that the pfizer covet 19
vaccine is safe and effective
and the fda has given its full and final
approval
so let me say this
loudly and clearly
if you have if you're one of the
millions of americans
who said that they will not get the shot
when it's until has full and final
approval of the fda
it has now happened
the moment you've been waiting for us
here it's time for you to go get your
vaccination and get it today
today
it's an important moment in our fight
against the pandemic
you know i want to thank the acting
commissioner janet woodcock and the
entire team at fda for their hard work
dr woodcock is a true professional she's
a career scientist who served under
republican presidents and democratic
presidents
she's ensured that the
team
followed the science above all
they've looked at the mountains of
clinical data clinical trial data
and the safety and efficiency data and
concluded without question the vaccine
was safe and effective for emergency use
in december that same thing we've got
those shots and arms at the time
350 million in the united states
and billions across the world
they kept pouring over this data the fda
approval
is the gold standard
and as i just said now it has been
granted
those who've been waiting for full
approval should go get your shot now
the vaccination is free
it's easy it's safe and it's effective
and it's convenient
for 90 of americans
there's a vaccination site less than
five miles from your home
and you can get the shot without an
appointment
so please get your shot today
there is no time to waste
the delta variant is dangerous and
spreading
causing a pandemic of the unvaccinated
that's the pandemic the unvaccinated
and while we're starting to see initial
signs that cases may be declining in a
few places
nationwide cases are still rising
especially among the unvaccinated
across the country
virtually all of the covet 19
hospitalizations and deaths
continue to be among the unvaccinated
that's worse in states where vaccination
rates are overall low
but even in states where many people are
vaccinated the unvaccinated are still at
risk let me be clear
there are cases where vaccinated people
do get covenant
but they are far less common than
unvaccinated people getting coveted and
most importantly their conditions are
far less severe
the overwhelming majority of people
in the hospital of covet 19 or almost
all those
dying from covet 19 are not vaccinated
not vaccinated if you're fully
vaccinated
both shots
plus
two weeks
your risk of severe illness covet 19 is
very very very low
now i know that parents are concerned
about covert 19 cases among their
children
i'll be addressing this soon with
secretary
cordona to discuss how we get our kids
back to school safely
cases among children are still rare
and severe cases among children are very
very rare but i know that parents are
thinking about their own kids
it's not as reassuring as anyone would
like it to be
so let me say this as parents to the
parents
as you have you have the tools you have
the tools to keep your child safer
and two of those tools above all are
available to you
one make sure that everyone around your
child
who can be vaccinated
is vaccinated parents adults teens
two
make sure your child is masked
when they leave home
that's how we can best keep our kids
safe
as i've said before
the pandemic of the unvaccinated is a
tragedy that is preventable
people are dying and will die who don't
have to
so please
please if you haven't gotten your
vaccination if you haven't gotten
vaccinated
do it now
it could save your life in the lives of
those you love
now
the good news is that people are getting
vaccinated
for the past several weeks my
administration has imposed new vaccine
requirements on federal workers
the armed forces
people work in federal medical
facilities and nursing home workers
governors mayors and private sector
leaders have done the same
we've also encouraged new incentives for
example in some states
you get a hundred dollars if you get
vaccinated
these new requirements and incentives
are accelerating vaccinations once again
giving us the hope
that we can put this delta variant
behind us in the weeks ahead
there are three facts everyone should
know about where we are in this fight
against this pandemic
first
even as the delta variant has ravaged
the unvaccinated
the deaths have client deaths have
climbed the death rate is still 70
percent lower than it was
last winter
why
because we did such a good job
vaccinating those most at risk
senior citizens
america has about 54 million senior
citizens
about 50 million have at least have
gotten at least one shot
that's almost 92 percent
secondly overall weekly new vaccinations
are up more than 56 percent from where
they were a month ago
last week
we saw a record of vaccinations
more than one million shots a day for
three state debt through three straight
days
this is the first time this has happened
since june
six million shots in the last seven days
the highest seven day total in over a
month and a half
remember remember when we were trying to
get 70 of the people over 18 at least
one shot
well we've not only gotten that done
we've gotten 71 percent
of everyone age 12 and older their first
shot and that's over 200 million
americans
and over 170 million are now fully
vaccinated
third
states that have been lagging
are seeing their vaccination rates grow
faster
in fact in alabama
arkansas louisiana and mississippi
more people got new vaccinations
in the past month
than the prior two months combined
the progress we're making on
vaccinations now is going to produce
results in the weeks ahead
the sooner you get fully vaccinated the
sooner you'll be protected
according to the experts from the yale
school of public health
the pace of our vaccination effort has
saved over 100 000 lives and have
prevented more than 450 000
hospitalizations
this is critical progress
when we need to move faster
as i mentioned before
i've imposed vaccination requirements
that will reach
millions of americans
today i'm calling on more country more
companies i should say in the private
sector
to step up with vaccine requirements
that'll reach millions more people
if you're a business leader
a non-profit leader
a state or local leader
who has been waiting for full fda
approval to require vaccinations i call
on you now to do that require it
do what i did last month require your
employees to get vaccinated
or face strict requirements
as i said last week vaccination
requirements have been around for
decades
students
healthcare professionals our troops are
typically required
to receive vaccinations to prevent
everything from polio to smallpox
measles mumps rubella
in fact the reason most people in
america don't worry about polio smallpox
measles mumps and rubella today is
because of vaccines
it only makes sense to require a vaccine
to stop the spread of covet 19.
with today's fda full approval there's
another good reason to get vaccinated
so
please get vaccinated now
if you go to vaccines.com
vaccines.com
or
text your zip code to 43-8829-438829
you can find a number of vaccine sites
near you
just minutes away
we can get your shot without an
appointment
all around the world people want these
vaccines here in america they're free
convenient and waiting for you
so please go today
for yourself for your loved ones for
your neighbors for your country
i'll close with this
we're in the midst of a wartime effort
to beat this pandemic
it's one of the biggest and most
complicated challenges in our history
and it's based on an unparalleled
vaccination program
that is saving lives and beating this
virus
it's a vaccination program
that's getting us back
to our loved ones
and the way of life we were used to it's
happening
and it's gonna keep happening
if you help it helps our economy
it gets everything moving it keeps us
growing
together
we've made significant progress in just
seven months
we just have to finish the job
with science
facts and confidence
together
together as a united states america
so please get vaccinated today god bless
you all and may god protect our troops
thank you
you
is
your password
this time
game